Жити - ось тут станція, цей довгий будинок.
Кімнати розраховані на двох людей.
Це має бути щось таке подібне до купе.
Лікарка з Києва Наталія Бабій -
часниця 24-ї наукової антарктичної експедиції
і буде жити цілий рік ось тут -
на українській антарктичній станції "Академік Вернадський"
що за понад 15 тисяч кілометрів від Києва.
Попереду ще два тижні зборів. Кожному полярнику
шиють спецкостюм і надають такий собі обов’язковий набір захисту -
окуляри, без яких краще за межі приміщення не виходити.
Грубо кажучи, опік і сітківки, і шкіри.
Наслідком може бути саме страшне і сліпота також.
Над станцією знаходиться озонова дірка. Умовно називається.
46-ти річна Наталія Бабій і 37-ми річна Оксана Савенко -
перші за останні 20 років жінки,
які беруть участь у науковій експедиції в Антарктиці.
Оксана Савенко -морська біологиня і вже на станції.
Вона написала DW, що працювати в Антарктиці -
була її мета ще зі студентських років.
Адже вона досліджує морських ссавців, зокрема - китів і тюленів.
А "Академік Вернадський" - для цього найкраще місце.
270 днів на рік - суцільні опади,
низька температура, сильні вітри.
Острів завдовжки до кілометра,
де ходити можна лише по визначених стежках:
деякі льодовикові ділянки небезпечні через щілини,
і діє загальноантарктична заборона
щодо зайвого втручання в біосферу.
Наталію це все не лякає. Вона затята туристка
і каже, що знає, "як перезимувати літо".
Адже їй доведеться з київської весни виїхати в полярну осінь.
Мені цікаво. Антарктида - це крайня точка Землі.
Це щось таке унікальне, куди мало хто може потрапити.
Оксана написала на своїй сторінці,
що її поява на станції викликала хвилю здивування серед іноземних колег.
Те, що українкам тут з’являтися зборонено,
стало в Антарктиді вже своєрідною притчею.
Новий керівник Антарктичного центру Євген Дикий
зізнається, що йому довелося боротися з відвертими науковими фейками про те що,
мовляв, є медичні заборони щодо перебування жінок в антарктичних умовах.
Чоловікам-урядовцям та науковцям він доводив,
що організм чоловіка і жінки однаковий, і що на станціях інших країн
вже давно живуть і працюють жінки.
А Німеччина кілька років тому
взагалі відправила в Антарктиду суто жіночу експедицію.
Ще кращий аргумент мені наводили
анонімно деякі наші старожили.
Якби наші дружини знали про те, що там є жінки, то нас би не пустили.
Ну, це знаєте…без коментарів!
Я сподіваюся, що вже через рік просто ніхто не згадуватиме
не ставитиме так питання, що ми забудемо, як страшний сон
те, що на 20 років ми вибилися з нормального цивілізованого людства і скотилися в "кіндер,
кірхен, кюхен". Мені, наприклад, дуже соромно, чесно кажучи, за нас як за країну.
Поява жінок в експедиції - це результат ще однієї гендерної революції
в науковому світі та його, можна сказати, декомунізації.
Раніше в експедиції обирали людей ледь не за правилами КДБ.
Але кілька місяців тому вперше за 20 років
був проведений відкритий відбір.
На 12-місячну експедицію було подано
неочікувано багато заявок - 179,
30 з яких від жінок. Відбирали за принципом рівності.
Людина, яка подається в експедицію, вона в такому разі не розглядається як чоловік чи жінка.
Вона розглядається як фахівець того чи іншого напрямку.
Якщо цього разу докторка виявилася сильніше за докторів,
то от вона і йде. Не тому що вона жінка, а тому що вона сильний доктор.
Наталія багато років працює хірургом,
допомагала пораненим майданівцям, воїнам АТО.
Для неї експедиція - чергове випробування.
Вона спокійна і через те, що залишає в Києві матір та чоловіка.
І через те, що не все можна взяти в експедицію.
Дозволено лише 40 кілограмів багажу,
а це в першу чергу спецодяг і взуття.
Тож, улюбленої кави можна взяти зовсім небагато,
а замість косметики треба брати просто багато крему.
Треба мати з собою запас кремів
для обличчя, тіла.
Це стосується і чоловіків, в тому числі. Гігієнічні помади.
Ще учасникам й учасницям експедиції, вважає Наталія,
треба подбати про запас вітамінів,
підготуватися до активних занять спортом, аби не набрати зайвої ваги
через гіподинамію - біч усіх зимувальників.
І бути психологічно готовим
до безконфліктного співіснування в маленькому колективі,
до відсутності можливості в будь-який момент виїхати
і навіть зв"язатися з рідними.
В попередні роки українці з острова писали по одному листу на тиждень.
Тепер мають ввечері лишу годину офіційного інтернету,
бо він там дуже дорогий: 5 тисяч доларів на місяць.
Науковий центр обіцяє покращувати умови
і навіть розшукує для експедиції свій корабель для перевезень.